you know subaru of las vegas the
sponsors of this next segment is
all about spreading love this time it's
through their back to school clothing
and shoe drive
we stopped by to learn more
it starts with the subaru love promise
and that's our commitment to provide
extraordinary customer service
but more than that to go out into the
community
and to be engaged to be involved
well one of the pillars of the subaru
love promise is subaru loves learning
and
we want to make that learning experience
as good as it can be for our youth here
in in las vegas
and so what we've got going on is we've
partnered with helen jidstrom elementary
school
and we have got a pretty much a dress to
impress
back to school clothes and shoe drive
going on
it started june 18th and it goes all the
way through july 24th
and we're just excited about being able
to support
the families and seeing you know good
good clothes being given out to
to these students we chose helen judge
strip elementary school because
74 of the students there are on
either reduced or free lunches and
that's an indicator that there are needs
in the home and that's where we want to
step in
and see what we can do to support the
[Music]
families
i remember going to school and
my parents not having a lot and we not
having a lot and i remember going and
putting cardboard and this wasn't just
me it was my sibling
putting cardboard in the bottom of our
shoes so that we
didn't have those holes and the ground
coming through
i just i have a passion to see families
supported and kids
actually feel feeling good about
themselves and and
being able to go and study and learn and
know that they've got people
that have their back
[Music]
we've got a huge box here at in our
showroom at subaru of las vegas and we
are inviting the public to bring
new or gently used clothes
shoes and for all ages
because we want to help the whole family
and so we're inviting you to bring that
out
all the way up until the 24th so on july
27th that's a tuesday the families of
the students that
attend hell and jed strip elementary
school they get to go between eight and
noon and they can go there
and it's it's called the subaru of las
vegas
uh closet event and they're gonna be
able to pick out clothes and shoes
not just for the students actually for
their entire family
thank you to subaru of las vegas for
sponsoring this segment for
more information call 702-495-2100 or
visit subaru
of lasvegas.com they have a special
offer for you
now through july 31st you can get 0 apr
financing
on select 2021 models for well-qualified
buyers
las vegas now